avec aurélien pradié le secrétaire
général avec nos collègues députés que
je vais vous présenter rapidement
nous sommes heureux de vous recevoir
donc j'ai du ster député de paris génie
d'ubs muller député de haute-savoie
constance le grip député des
hauts-de-seine maximino député de l'oise
et puis une délégation de think tanks
appelé le millénaire qui s'intéresse
aussi aux questions de culture
donc aujourd'hui nous souhaitons vous
présenter le plan d'urgence des
républicains pour sauver la culture donc
excepté la déclaration à la fois très
très grande île où quand et malgré tout
lacunaire par le président de la
république le 6 mai la culture a été
très peu considérée depuis le début de
cette crise il n'y aurait de bercy
absente des stratégies de sauvetage et
de relance de l'économie alors même que
la culture représentent 2 3% du pib et
près de 1 million 300 mille salariés ou
emploi et pourtant le confinement a
causé l'annulation d'un très grand
nombre de manifestations 65 mille
spectacles ont été annulés durant ce
confinement et les pertes se chiffrent
en milliards d'euros
toutes les disciplines tous les
territoires sont concernés c'est la
raison pour laquelle les républicains ne
peuvent se résoudre à ce désastre
culturel dont les effets pourraient être
durablement dramatique en raison de la
fragilité de ce secteur pourtant
essentiel à la vie de la nation
je voudrais en deux mots vous rappeler
que la culture et la droite ou la droite
et la culture
c'est une très longue histoire d'andré
malraux bien sûr notre figure du
commandeur jusqu'à nicolas sarkozy qui
est le dernier président de la
république avoir sanctuariser le budget
de la culture
nous avons eu de très grands ministres
de la culture de très grand président
centre beaubourg pour évoquer le
président pompidou
évidemment la grande figure emblématique
de jacques duhamel qui avait créé le 1
pour cent culturel à notre président
jacques chirac qui a fondé le quai
branly et reconnu les arts premiers
valéry giscard d'estaing la gare d'orsay
nicolas sarkozy je le disais donc notre
famille politique a toujours c'est
toujours beaucoup intéressé aux
questions culturelles
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
souhaité apporter notre contribution en
ce moment si particulier du confinement
suivi du déconfinement en vous
présentant ce matin un plan d'urgence et
en esquissant les lignes de ce que
pourrait être un plan de relance un plan
qui présente à la fois une ambition et
une méthode des mesures générales qui
s'applique à l'ensemble du secteur
culturel mais aussi des mesures
spécifiques par discipline dont le
chiffrage avoisine les 350 millions
d'euros dans les mesures générales
trois d'entre elles que je voudrais
évoquer rapidement tout d'abord le
maintien du chômage partiel jusqu'à la
fin de l'année pour les pme et les tpe
l'annulation des charges fiscales et
sociales sur le principe du 070 charge
et enfin un fonds de soutien à
l'ensemble des acteurs de la culture qui
pourraient se répartir selon la règle
des deux tiers pour l'état un tiers pour
les collectivités en ponctionnant en
particulier les crédits du pass culture
dont nous considérons qu'il a été
davantage un gadget de campagne qu'un
véritable programme culturel et j'en
veux pour preuve la difficulté à le voir
se déployer efficacement sur le
territoire il touche un très petit
nombre de jeunes et en plus il est dans
une logique consumériste qui n'est pas
du tout la logique que nous voulons voir
appliquer sur le territoire qui est
véritablement l'éducation du spectateur
et puis le soutien à l'ensemble de la
filière
alors nous avons donc posé le principe
d'une ambition d'une véritable ambition
qui est chiffré mais nous avons voulu
aussi entrer dans le détail des
différentes disciplines culturelles
à commencer par le spectacle vivant dont
je vous disais à quel point il avait été
touché par cette crise sanitaire et en
même temps à part quelques déclarations
ici ou là relativement peu pris en
compte
je vais vous en donner une preuve comme
mes collègues parlementaires chaque
semaine pendant la crise sanitaire
nous avons eu des rendez vous avec nos
préfets chaque semaine en audio
conférence ou en visioconférence est ce
qu'une seule fois mes chers collègues
vous avez vu le drac invités à ces
réunions
on a eu leurs représentants des
différents secteurs de l'économie du
social
jamais les préfets n'ont invité les
dracs ou les dragues nous se sont
invités à des conférences pour évoquer
la situation de la culture dans nos
territoires
c'est vraiment la démonstration que ce
sujet finalement outre les quelques
déclarations de principe n'a pas été
véritablement traité alors plus quelques
mois sur le spectacle vivant qui est
probablement un des secteurs les plus
les plus touchés d'autant que à l'aube
de l'été
beaucoup de festivals les festivals ont
été annulés les grands comme les petits
rendez vous malgré cette distinction un
peu artificielle entre petits et grands
festivals donc vous avez le dossier de
presse vous pourrez en prendre
connaissance de façon détaillée gisèle
ray trois mesures qui me paraissent
emblématique
il ne suffit pas de décréter la
réouverture des théâtres pour que
ceux-ci réouvre c'est vraiment
méconnaître le fonctionnement de ce
secteur pour pouvoir juger les choses
ainsi nous nous avons une méthode
opérationnel nous proposons que tous les
théâtres toutes les salles ré ouvre en
septembre parce que la véritable rentrée
elle se fera en septembre
et pour respecter les mesures sanitaires
nous proposons d'occuper de prévoir que
seul un tiers de la jauge souhaite
occuper mais pour cela il faut et pour
couvrir le même volume de spectateurs il
faut inciter à ce qu' il y ait trois
représentations au lieu d'une et inciter
à ce que deux des mesures soient
financées par l'état et les
collectivités de sur les trois
représentations soient financés par
l'état et les collectivités
donc c'est une mesure importante qui
dont le coût avoisinerait les 190
millions d'euros mais qui seuls sont de
nature à permettre évidemment au monde
du spectacle vivant de surmonter cette
crise une autre mesure est de créer un
fonds de soutien de transitoire pour les
invisibles mais peut-être que aurélien
pradié reviendra c'est une mesure à
laquelle il était particulièrement
attaché
l'écosystème de la culture fait qu' il y
à toutes sortes d'acteurs professionnels
qui interviennent et qui ne sont
protégés ni par le statut
l'intermittence ni par le chômage
partiel
enfin nous proposons créer un fonds
d'urgence spécifiques dotés de 46
millions d'euros pour les ensembles
indépendants qui sont dans une situation
extrêmement difficile sur le patrimoine
beaucoup de mesures ont été pensés et
peut-être que constance le grip si elle
le souhaite pourra intervenir mais nous
pensons que le patrimoine est un pan
extrêmement important de la relance
relance culturelle relance aussi en
matière de bâtiment puisque le
patrimoine ce sont des artisans des
compagnons des entreprises qui
interviennent pour le pour sa rénovation
et il y a en la matière beaucoup de
choses à proposer mais peut-être
constance pourras-tu en dire quelques
mots sur le cinéma
nous nous souhaitons la réouverture
immédiate de tous les cinémas
c'est le premier loisir culturel les
français les salles de cinéma peuvent
réouvrir dès maintenant
il n'est pas nécessaire d'attendre
davantage d'autant que
les professionnels du cinéma ont déjà
élaboré un protocole sanitaire ils
savent ce sont des professionnels de
l'accueil du public
ils savent faire et je pense que sur la
proposition qu'ils ont faite nous
pouvons reprendre les tournages
immédiatement et nous pouvons réouvrir
les salles immédiatement et organiser
ses leurs suggestions et nous l'avons
reprise
une grande fête du cinéma à l'automne
sur l'audiovisuel secteur dans lequel
virginie duby muller vous dira également
je pense quelques mots il y avait
matière à faire également en alignement
du crédit d'un point de vue visuel en
relançant également les investissements
publicitaires en transposant
immédiatement la directive européenne
sur le livre un mot si vous le permettez
pour avoir travaillé un peu plus
particulièrement sur ce sujet dans le
passé la france jouit d'une situation
tout à fait particulière en ce sens
qu'elle est maillé sur l'ensemble du
territoire par un réseau de librairies
indépendantes ce qui en fait
véritablement une exception culturelle
souvent ce terme est galvaudé mais pour
le coup en ce qui concerne le livre nous
sommes véritablement dans une situation
particulière la france est riche de ses
milliers de librairies indépendantes et
l'enjeu est tout simplement leur survie
et pour ce faire nous souhaitons que les
collectivités si elle le voulait level
naturellement et je crois qu'elles le
veulent puissent adapter le code des
marchés publics pour privilégier ce
réseau quand elles font des commandes
pour leur établissement conclure un
partenariat avec la poste pour pouvoir
rivaliser que les plateformes vous savez
que certaines plateformes dont on ne
donnera pas le nom mais auquel chacun
pense se sont trouvés très avantagés par
la crise puisque le e-commerce a
fonctionné à plein y compris en matière
de livre donc plusieurs propositions
concernant le livre dont est
les librairies indépendantes dont la
fragilité est avérée et dont la
situation est des plus précaires
beaucoup de mesures concernant les arts
plastiques qui est un domaine qui a été
complètement passé sous silence
à l'exception de la commande aux jeunes
artistes mais je ne crois pas que le
talent s'évanouissent avec l'âge donc
quid des autres artistes quid de tous
les artistes les créateurs qui
aujourd'hui sont dans une situation très
difficile qui ne peuvent pas exposer et
là nous allons nous en avons profité
pour faire un focus assez approfondies
pour soutenir les galeries en créant un
contrat de trois ans pour installer une
relation stable entre les artistes et
les galeries ou en créant réseau
european galerie ou un grand événement
ou paris pourrait restaurer sa place et
sa primauté pour soutenir les uns les
artistes également instauré un droit de
suite pour rémunérer les artistes lors
de la vente de leurs oeuvres sur le
second marché pour créer un droit de
représentation de leurs rêves ou pour
lancer une campagne en faisant appel aux
mécènes aux entreprises 1000 commandes
pour 1000 artistes
donc voilà brossé à grands traits les
deux mêmes sectoriel dans lesquels nous
avons fait des propositions précises
et puis nous reviendrons ensuite sur la
la suite des opérations si je puis dire
mais là j'invite peut-être notre
secrétaire général à prendre la parole
est ensuite nos collègues diront
quelques mots de la partie puis sur les
prendront la parole tout à fait
librement sur les sujets qui les
intéressent
merci annie genevard pour cet art pente
important travail qui a été conduit je
veux la saluer dans son implication
considérable autour de cette question de
la culture saluer nos collègues
parlementaires qui chacun ont amené leur
expertise et leur engagement sur ces
questions là et puis le millénaire qui
nous a beaucoup accompagné aussi la
culture est un sujet absolument
stratégique
le fait que nous soyons réunis
aujourd'hui au siège et républicains
pour présenter ce plan est la
démonstration du caractère stratégique
que nous donnons à la culture
d'abord c'est un sujet stratégique pour
la droite
historiquement la droite républicaine
depuis le général de gaulle annie a
retracé cette grande histoire a toujours
eu un engagement fort politique autour
des questions culturelles et peut-être
l'avion nous ont oubliés depuis quelque
temps il vous le savez dans la volonté
qui est la nôtre désormais ici dans
cette maison il ya cette préoccupation
importante qui est de réinvestir tous
les champs de la discussion politique la
culture fait partie de ces champs peut
être oublié mais qui sont absolument
incontournable il ya donc un premier
message qui est un message politique à
notre rencontre de ce matin consistant à
dire que nous renouons avec cette grande
histoire de la droite culturel et de
l'ambition qu'elle a toujours eu pour la
nation et pour une nation forte en
matière de culture
je voudrais insister sur le caractère
stratégique du plan du point de vue
économique la culture aujourd'hui fait
partie de ces secteurs qui sont parfois
un peu masqué dans les grands plans de
relance que l'on peut annoncer mais qui
peuvent assez facilement faire
concurrence des grands secteurs
économiques industriels qu'on identifie
fasse de manière plus aisée sûrement
mais qui ondes qui relève de secteurs
qui tiennent une économie de premier et
de second plan absolument majeur partout
dans nos territoires
enfin je voudrais dire pour nous c'est
un sujet stratégique parce que au moment
où il faudra et c'est déjà le cas
aujourd'hui
reconstruire notre pays il faudra le
reconstruire économiquement il faudra le
reconstruire socialement mais il faudra
aussi être capable de porter un projet
politique qui donne de l'espoir et la
culture fait partie de ces grands
projets politiques qui ont toujours été
au rendez vous des grandes
reconstruction historique de notre
nation mais aussi de toutes les grandes
nations du monde et des nations
européennes en particulier vous ne
trouverez pas dans l'histoire de ces
nations de moments de reconstruction y
compris à l'après guerre aux après
guerre qui ait fait l'impasse sur la
culture et la culture a toujours été un
élément de ferme en national absolument
fondamental voilà pourquoi depuis
plusieurs semaines et plusieurs mois et
pour l'ensemble de nos collègues qui
sont engagées depuis plusieurs années
sur ces questions culturelles et
républicains se sont
au travail ont consulté des acteurs des
experts des femmes et des hommes venus
de tous horizons pour pouvoir
aujourd'hui vous présenter ce programme
annie genevard l'a dit c'est à la fois
un plan d'urgence parce qu'il ya urgence
à sauver le monde de la culture
son tissu économique et son ambition
pour l'avenir mais c'est aussi un plan
de long terme avec des pistes qui sont
ouvertes qui pour certaines sont très
aboutis qui pour d'autres vont continuer
à être creusés dans les mois et les
années qui viennent et qui permette de
reposer la question culturelle au centre
du débat politique tel que nous
l'imaginons jeu les républicains
il ya quelques pistes précises sur
lesquelles je voudrais dire un mot
d'abord annie genevard a évoqué le grand
flou qu'il y a eu dans les annonces
présidentielles ce grand fou c'est pas
seulement une erreur de communication
c'est aussi révélateur de l'idée que la
macro ni se fait de la culture et en
particulier que l'idée que de l'idée que
le président de la république se fait la
culture au fond c'est l'idée d'un gadget
l'idée d'un jouet soit un jouet
révélateurs sont ainsi narcissisme plus
que autre chose
là où nous voulons véritablement offert
une ambition nationale et une ambition
politique et parmi les angles morts des
déclarations présidentielles
il ya notamment le secteur des oubliés
des invisibles dont nous parlions tout à
l'heure nous identifions assez
facilement celles et ceux qui relèvent
du régime des intermittents du spectacle
assez facilement les grands artistes
mais on identifie plus difficilement les
maquilleuses les guides patrimoniaux et
et tant d'autres qui ne relève d'aucun
de ces secteurs là aucun de ces domaines
là et qui sont en train de disparaître
du monde culturel et du monde économique
et au delà de l'enjeu économique majeure
que cela représente de l'enjeu social il
ya aussi un risque considérable
d'effondrement de compétences qui seront
nécessaires à la relance de tous les
secteurs de la culture
je voudrais poursuivre d'un dernier mot
en vous disant que au coeur de ce
programme vous trouverez une série de
mesures chiffrées sérieuse rigoureuse
mais aussi ambitieuse et vous
retrouverez ou retrouverez une ambition
que la droite républicaine a toujours
porté dans beaucoup de domaines mais
notamment dans le domaine culturel
qui suit la commande publique les
républicains la droite a toujours cru en
la commande publique pas la commande
publique qui se substitue au secteur
privé non la commande publique qui est
capable de donner un cap qui est capable
de lancer des initiatives d'ouvrir des
pistes
c'est vrai sur le domaine des arts
plastiques
c'est vrai aussi sur le domaine de la
librairie et du livre qui était un
secteur essentiel de notre nation dans
ce projet vous verrez à quel point nous
avons pour ambition de reposer la
commande publique comme étant un élément
locomotive de la reconstruction du
projet culturel je serai pas plus long
je conclurai simplement au delà des
remerciements en vous disant que ce type
de présentation nous fait du bien ce
peut parfois que nous soyons un peu
focaliser les uns et les autres sur des
sujets qui font notre actualité qui font
l'actualité du pays de temps en temps de
se repositionner sur des sujets de long
terme sur des sujets aussi essentiels
que celui de la culture
cela nous fait du bien chez les
républicains j'imagine que ça peut faire
du bien aussi au débat politique
aurélia alors chers collègues qui veut
prendre la parole bien quelques mots
d'abord pour remercier évidemment annie
et aurélien d'avoir coordonné ce gros
travail
les membres de la culture de la
commission culture éducation évidemment
avons l'habitude de travailler sur ces
sujets il était important évidemment que
notre famille politique puisse
s'exprimer
c'est effectivement un point important
dans notre pib
et il aura fallu d'ailleurs attendre
2013 pour qu'un rapport est bien mesure
la porte de la culture dans l'économie
et vous savez évidemment il a un poids
important et qui permet d'irriguer tout
un écosystème
moi je vais vous parler des propositions
qui ont été faites en matière
d'audiovisuel
d'abord la suspension de la taxe sur les
services de télévision pour 2020 c'est
une demande importante des chaînes qui
ont subi et bien un effondrement de
leurs recettes publicitaires et
évidemment nous sommes très favorables à
ces demandes
aligner le crédit impôt audiovisuels sur
celui du cinéma évidemment annie en a
parlé
et puis nous proposons également l'un
crédit d'impôt communication qui
permettrait est bien de relancer les
recettes publicitaires
celles ci se sont effondrés évidemment
il ya une culture française particulière
en matière de marketing par rapport à
d'autres pays notamment européens
aujourd'hui évidemment ça a des
conséquences et bien à la fois sur les
chaînes mais aussi sur les radios sur la
presse quotidienne régionale et il est
important et bien qu'on défende cette
proposition il y aura un projet de loi
de finances rectificative numéro trois
et ça fera partie des sujets que nous
porterons il avait déjà été évoquée au
sénat et puis évidemment un autre sujet
qui nous paraît important est bien c'est
de transposer rapidement la directive et
sema il se trouve que juste avant le
confinement nous étions en débat sur le
projet de loi audiovisuel
d'ailleurs il ya eu un certain nombre de
collègues qui ont été contaminés y
compris le ministre de la culture lui
même et à l'occasion et bien du débat de
et de l'examen de ce texte
ces directives et sema devait être
transposée
vous savez que elle est très importante
parce qu'elle permettra de faire
contribuer les plateformes à la création
qu'il ya aussi des impératifs européens
et donc il faut aller très vite alors
désormais nous n'avons pas je dirais
d'information sur la date à laquelle
sera examiné ce texte mais
vraisemblablement il devrait être
saucissonné et notamment cette directive
et sema devra peut-être être introduite
par par des ordonnances
vraisemblablement le gouvernement
trouvera d'autres moyens pour pour le
faire adopter par ce que il y a urgence
donc voilà rapidement quelles sont nos
positions sur le secteur audiovisuel qui
est évidemment très important qui est
pourvoyeur d'emplois qui un rôle
évidemment aussi dans notre économie
locale à travers lychen la pqr et les
radios locales et nous sommes évidemment
les relais de tout cet écosystème merci
bonjour à tous brigitte kuster député de
paris moi je voudrais vous dire
aujourd'hui c'est un moment important et
je remercie en effet aurélien pradié
annie genevard d'avoir organiser
coordonner ce travail
que nous menons entre députés l'est
républicain à la commission des affaires
culturelles de mettre la culture
en effet en avant aujourd'hui et ça
n'est pas rien ce qui est en train de se
passer parce que bien souvent on a
l'impression que la droite ne prend pas
en compte la thématique de la culture et
les problématiques qui en découle la
culture bien sûr c'est une politique
culturelle et puis ce sont des acteurs
culturels et c'était important
aujourd'hui de montrer la difficulté
dans laquelle se trouve beaucoup de
secteurs beaucoup de deux personnes du
monde du théâtre du cinéma de les aider
de les accompagner
c'est d'autant plus important que dans
le cadre du plan présenté par le
président de la république il y avait de
nombreux trous dans la raquette et que
le monde de la culture s'est sentis
oubliés bien souvent abandonnés à cela
aussi une raison importante c'est que le
président de la république n'a jamais
porté la culture comme une priorité
on ne pouvait pas dire ça d'ailleurs de
ses prédécesseurs ne serait-ce que de
françois mitterrand la culture ne
l'habite pas et à partir de ce moment là
le ministère de la culture est dépossédé
on le voit nous avons un ministère qui
est diminuée pour chaque thématique nous
avons à chaque fois une personnalité
extérieure stéphane bern pour le
patrimoine
erik orsenna pour le livre le général
georgelin pour notre dame etc etc
ce ministère est un ministère capital et
mettre aujourd'hui la culture au coeur
du projet des républicains est un
événement important
nous bataillons chaque fois au moment du
budget entre nous parfois même au sein
de notre propre parti sur la culture
ça peut arriver on défend les crédits
d'impôts au théâtre cinéma spectacles
vivants et bien c'est sous ce
gouvernement macron par exemple que le
crédit d'impôt spectacle a été diminuée
pour lé cabaret les spectacles d'humour
et bien cette manière de déposséder la
culture le monde culturel les
professionnels de la culture c'est
quelque chose que nous ne pouvons plus
accepter alors nous travaillons comme
des petites fourmis avec des
propositions chaque fois dans les
commissions des affaires culturelles
et puis aujourd'hui avec un plan de
relance qui tient vraiment la route
c'est un plan de relance importants qui
est fait sur les urgences mais c'est
aussi un plan qui prend date pour la
suite
et bien aujourd'hui les républicains
vous dise combien ils sont fiers d'être
au rendez vous de la culture et j'espère
que le monde culturel aura à coeur de se
réapproprier aussi le débat avec nous et
de continuer ensemble pour porter haut
et fort cette exception culturelle
française dont nous sommes tous si fier
merci merci brigitte merci annie merci
aurélien d'avoir permis effectivement
qui lie ce matin cette présentation de
notre projet pour sauver la culture
nous avons bataillé ça vient d'être
excellent amendis avec vous par brigitte
kuster depuis souvent de longs mois de
deux longues années dans différents
cénacle et notamment à nationale et au
sénat pour porter ensemble de
propositions y compris quelques fois à
l'inter de notre famille politique
fallait-il un petit peu haussé le ton
pour être entendu il est donc tout à
fait bienvenu que ce matin ici au siège
de notre famille politique on porte haut
et fort je dirais les couleurs d'une
ambition culturelle pour la france je
crois que là pas de confinement strict
et de cristal iter aiguë dans laquelle
nous nous sommes brutalement trouvée
plongée nous français et européens a
fait prendre conscience à celles et ceux
qui n'en avaient pas encore pleinement
pris conscience que la culture est un
bien de première nécessité
la culture est un bien de première
nécessité
je vais aborder plus particulièrement
les propositions que nous formulons dans
le domaine du patrimoine hors ma double
qualité de vice président de la
commission des affaires culturelles de
l'assemblée nationale et deux co
présidents du groupe d'étude sur le
patrimoine à l'assemblée nationale il se
trouve que le patrimoine et nous l'avons
amèrement déploré amèrement déploré a
été le grand absent le grand oublié du
discours à ses yeux grandiloquent à bien
des égards du présent macron lors de sa
présentation aux acteurs culturels du 6
mai dernier un mot au passage très léger
sur les métiers d'art mais un grand
grand absent le patrimoine a pas eu les
faveurs du verbe présidentiel à telle
enseigne d'ailleurs qu'il a fallu que
stéphane bern s'émeuvent et puis en face
des tonnes
dans les jours et les semaines qui ont
suivi pour dire qu'il s'agissait là d'un
oublier que non non le patrimoine était
toujours important force est de
constater que malgré la mission berne
malgré le lancement du loto du
patrimoine dont je rappelle que c'est
une idée qui avait été portée il ya des
années déjà de cela par notre famille
politique par un éminent mère
versaillais de notre famille politique
françois manière il est obligé à tout
observateur un peu objectif de constater
que le patrimoine la valorisation la
promotion la protection à la défense du
patrimoine ne figure pas au coeur de la
politique culturelle de ce gouvernement
nous avons donc nous fait notre en
quelque sorte le très jolis mots de
philippe bélaval qu'il a partagée devant
les membres de la commission des
affaires culturelles à l'occasion d'un
récente audition que j'avais copiloté
philippe bélaval le présent du centre
des monuments nationaux qui nous dit
c'est un très joli mot encore une fois
que nous faisons nôtre le patrimoine est
un antidote
le patrimoine est un antidote le
patrimoine en ce qu'il a de permanents
de stable de durable de pérenne de
rassurant et quelque chose vers lequel
les françaises et les français dans des
moments où ils peuvent douter souffrir
être perdu être confrontés à des
questions existentielles il ya des
problèmes quotidiens et nous savons les
problèmes qui vont surgir dans les
semaines et les mois à venir peuvent se
tourner vers le patrimoine pense qu'il a
encore une fois de rassurant le
patrimoine est un antidote et donc il
est absolument vital et c'est au
confluent des biens des valeurs de notre
famille politique que d'assurer la
préservation la protection et la défense
du patrimoine ce sont des entreprises
des emplois un savoir-faire une
excellence des métiers absolument unique
et l'excellence française qui est
également un facteur de rayonnement
culturel et touristique
autour de notre patrimoine doivent être
reconnus mais il y a également cette
dimension patrimoniale ancrée au coeur
des valeurs de la droite républicaine
encore une fois le passé les racines
l'identité la transmission l'héritage
beaucoup des valeurs qui sont les nôtres
se retrouvent dans notre envie de
valoriser de défendre de promouvoir et
de permettre pour patrimoine d'être
pleinement reconnue comme un élément
central d'une ambition nationale d'une
ambition culturelle française nous
formulons quelques propositions très
précises tant pour le patrimoine public
le patrimoine le privé parce que nous
n'oublions pas qu'il y avait énormément
d'opérateurs privés engagés dans le
patrimoine de très très nombreux ça se
chiffre par plusieurs milliers
propriétaires privés des monuments
historiques il nous faut pouvoir insiste
éric ouvert au public bien sûr qu'il
faut pouvoir accompagner et soutenir
dans l'extraordinaire mission qu'ils
remplissent nous proposons des
dispositions fiscales par exemple celle
d'une suspension temporaire de l'impôt
sur la fortune immobilière pour les
propriétaires de monuments historiques
privés ouverts au public châteaux
manoirs demeure historique parcs et
jardins doivent pouvoir être protégés et
donc doivent pouvoir bénéficier d'une un
allègement de la charge fiscale nous
proposons également parce que trop
souvent les lourdeurs bureaucratiques
administrative pèse sur bien des
propriétaires de monuments que puisse
être simplifiées ensemble de procédures
de conventionnement de monuments
historiques parce que les procédures
sont très longues prennent souvent
plusieurs années avant de pouvoir être
reconnu comme détenteur d'un monument
historique pouvant être conventionnée
déclencher un ensemble de choses
nous proposons également un renforcement
du loto du patrimoine l'initiative que
nous avions salué je faisais allusion
tout à l'heure le proposons que cet
instrument soit renforcé et que soit mis
fin à la belle rente situation de la
ponction fiscale de la ponction de taxe
sur le produit de ce loto du patrimoine
à lièpvre que nous avions soulevés
que moi en plein coeur d'une séance de
nuit budgétaire et qui a fait
effectivement bondir tous les acteurs du
patrimoine nous souhaitons qu'il soit
mis fin à la perception des taxes sur
les recettes du loto du patrimoine vous
verrez dans le dossier beaucoup d'autres
propositions également en matière de
préservation et d'augmentation des
moyens de la puissance publique pour le
patrimoine dans les collectivités
locales que l'état doivent pouvoir être
plus à même d'accompagner et de soutenir
le patrimoine et tous les acteurs du
patrimoine je n'oublie pas et j'en
termine par là la dimension du mécénat
culturel nous savons que les entreprises
françaises devront avoir à faire face à
l'ensemble des difficultés et économique
et financière mais il nous faut
néanmoins réfléchir à rénover adaptées
peut-être affiner certains dispositifs
du mécénat culturel pour qu' il puisse y
avoir toujours cet apport de recettes
important aussi bien pour les monuments
privé que pour les monuments publics
voilà encore une fois le patrimoine au
coeur de notre ambition culturelle pour
la france
merci je vais je pas rajouté grand chose
parce que vous avez déjà beaucoup
beaucoup dit je voudrais avant tout à
remercier effectivement aurélien d'avoir
pris l'initiative de créer ce plan de
relance de la culture côté aux côtés
d'annie c'est important que la droite
effectivement se saisissent de ce sujet
et puis il faut pas l'oublier ce plan de
relance est avant tout une première
pierre dans notre édifice pour ce plan
de relance de la culture
je voudrais notamment faire un point
d'honneur sur les conférences
territoriales qui seront mises à
l'honneur en septembre prochain puisque
en tant qu'ancien maire il est vrai que
nous sommes tous en tout cas attaché à
ce que la culture viennent dans nos
territoires qui sont parfois isolés
parfois complètement démuni de la
culture il est important de d'aller voir
nos élus locaux sur le territoire pour
qu'ils puissent effectivement année la
culture au plus proche de leurs
concitoyens et puis il y aura également
les les forums des républicains avec les
acteurs de la culture et je pense que ça
c'est une très bonne initiative qui est
très attendue donc encore merci en tout
cas notre famille politique
d'avoir saisi le sujet de la culture
pour pour l'avenir merci beaucoup merci
maxime quelques mots donc sur les
perspectives donc un plan d'urgence vous
l'avez compris qui est destiné à
préserver les structures les
manifestations et les acteurs de la
culture
mais nous ne nous arrêterons pas là
c'est véritablement la première pierre
de notre projet pour la culture
et comme vient de le dire maxime de
choses à vous annoncer
pas une dont nous suggérons aux
gouvernements qu'ils l'appliquent
il s'agit des conférences territoriales
pour refonder la politique publique de
la culture
vous le savez plus de 70% de la culture
est assumée budgétairement par les
collectivités locales et territoriales
beaucoup d'entre nous ont été maires ou
ont présidé une
intercommunalité ou ont été élus sur des
listes municipales et savent l'apport
extraordinaire des collectivités
territoriales et locales et
singulièrement le bloc local communes
intercommunalité à la culture en france
c'est d'ailleurs pour nous un sujet de
grand étonnement de constater que le
président de la république n'a pas fait
mention
s'il ne fallait compter que sur l'aide
de l'état pour faire vivre la culture en
france
celle ci serait évidemment
considérablement diminué donc nous nous
considérons qu'il faut agir au plus près
des territoires et au fond nous invitons
gouvernement à réfléchir à une forme de
décentralisation de déconcentration
culturel
nous croyons aux services déconcentrés
de la culture les dracs doivent
continuer d'exister mais elles doivent
remplir sans doute plus efficacement
leur rôle de coordination et c'est bien
le sens que nous donnons à ces
conférences territoriales afin que
chacun se mette autour de la table pour
voir qu'est ce qu'il faut préserver
qu'est-ce qu'il faut soutenir qu'est-ce
qu'il faut promouvoir en matière de
culture sur les territoires c'est avec
notre pays
montceau nord d'une tradition culturelle
qui malheureusement souffre depuis de
nombreuses années nous qui sommes
membres de la commission des affaires
culturelles et de l'éducation
nous voyons bien que depuis un
quinquennat et demi les choses peine à
exister en matière de culture
on a vu deux sujets émergé en huit ans
c'est un l'éducation artistique et
culturelle nous qui en sommes les
promoteurs sur le terrain nous voyons
bien que au niveau national ça patine
terriblement on touche trop peu de monde
ce sont des grand messes mais qui ne
sont pas suffisamment opérationnelle sur
le terrain
et puis la question de la diversité
culturelle qui a saturé le débat public
en matière de culture
or je crois que ce sont de mauvaises
pistes
non pas que l'éducation artistique et
culturelle soit une mauvaise piste mais
telle qu'elle est conduite dans notre
pays en ignorant les
initiatives qui sont prises en local
c'est une mauvaise façon de voir les
choses
puis la question de la diversité
culturelle nous a fait nous abîmer dans
des débats idéologiques sans fin
en oubliant ce qui était l'essentiel
c'est à dire véritablement l'application
des politiques publiques en matière de
culture donc nous pensons que ces
conférences territoriales au plus près
des territoires avec les services
déconcentrés de l'état probablement à
échelle départementale les régions
aujourd'hui sont trop vastes beaucoup
trop vaste pour pouvoir conduire des
politiques de proximité que je suppose
la culture et une politique de l'offre
parce que la culture c'est une politique
de l'offre il faut offrir pour susciter
la demande
c'est une des caractéristiques sans
doute de ce secteur d'activité et puis
le deuxième donc nous nous aimerions que
ces conférences territoriales elles
puissent avoir lieu dès la rentrée donc
nous interpellons gouvernement nous lui
disons soyez reprenez une initiative des
républicains
car nous la croyons
bonne et surtout féconde pour l'avenir
et puis la deuxième initiative que nous
allons prendre et de lancer à la rentrée
un forum des républicains des acteurs de
la culture nous avons vous le savez là
nous rejoignons la politique générale
dès ce premier tour des élections
municipales gagné près de 56% des villes
de plus de 9000 habitants et dans toutes
ces villes il y à des acteurs des
adjoints à la culture qui pourrait nous
faire profiter utilement de leur
expérience
donc nous ferons à la rentrée un forum
des républicains au tour des acteurs de
la culture avant de réfléchir à ce qui
pourrait être demain une politique
culturelle accompli efficace qui
réduisent les fracture culturelle sur
notre territoire qui bien sûr donne une
fois encore l'illustration de toute
l'importance que nous accordons à la
culture dans notre famille politique
voilà je voudrais remercier sincèrement
d'abord les journalistes qui sont
présents par voie dématérialisée ou en
présence ce matin remercie aussi tous
ceux qui nous ont aidés qui nous ont
éclairés de leurs compétences serge
lefrançois le millénaire qui est présent
derrière nous et puis évidemment les
ervices des républicains qui ont
travaillé activement à la réalisation de
ce document et qui ont contribué à
enrichir notre réflexion la matière je
vous remercie et nous sommes prêts à
répondre à vos questions
350 millions plan d'urgence
alors je ne veux pas botter en touche
vous savez que c'est un sujet sensible
président de la république annoncé une
année blanche c'est à dire que les
intermittents du spectacle ne
souffriront pas de l'absence de travail
durant la période du confinement
même si il se pose un certain nombre de
questions pratiques composer les les
intermittents du spectacle the eux-mêmes
j'ajoute que le président de la
république a annoncé une mesure mais que
en réalité sont les partenaires sociaux
qui négocient ces affaires là et qu' il
ne suffit pas de les décréter ex
cathedra pour que ça se déroule sans
problème nous nous avons simplement
soulevé la question des invisibles sur
ceux qui ne sont pas couverts par ce
statut
il ya aussi des questions techniques qui
se posent sur la dette anniversaire mais
je ne veux pas entrer dans ces détails
en tout cas toute réforme du statut de
l'intermittence n'est pas ni le lieu ni
le moment
à mon sens pour aborder ce sujet parce
que nous sommes véritablement là dans le
plan d'urgence c'est à dire sauver le
secteur culturel en matière d'emploi
culturel le président a fait ces
annonces on verra comment elles seront
mises en oeuvre
oui constance oui nous aurons l'occasion
en écoutant en échangeant avec les
professionnels les représentants des
intermittents de voir s'il ya lieu de
toiletter ou éventuellement réformer tel
ou tel aspect moi je voulais simplement
attirer également votre attention sur
des invisibles entre guillemets je ne
sais pas si l'expression est tout à fait
pour ce qui les concerne adéquate les
oubliés qui ne sont ni des intermittents
ni des salariés et qui sont beaucoup
passé sous les radars des dispositifs
d'urgence mis en place par le
gouvernement pendant la période de crise
de lakovic ce sont les auteurs qui sont
dans un no man's land juridique un flou
qui n'a rien d'artistique qui n'ont ni
de statut stabiliser ni de régime social
ou de régimes de retraite stabiliser
et conforter et qui ont vu les
conséquences de la crise aujourd'hui
mais surtout dans les mois et les années
à venir certainement parce qu'il va y
avoir des effets est de plus en plus
deux pour de nombreux auteurs s'avérait
être extrêmement cruelle ya actuellement
une mission flash que j'ai le plaisir de
copiloter avec un collègue d'une autre
famille politique au sein de la
commission des affaires culturelles qui
va réfléchir et faire des propositions
pour un statut ou des statues des
auteurs qui permettent de reconnaître la
spécificité de cette occupation
professionnelle si essentielle si on
parle culture en parle création et donc
on parle auteurs et artistes auteurs
j'aurai à dire d'ailleurs à ce sujet que
ils se sont heurtés à une difficulté
s'ils n'ont pas de numéro de siret
ils ne sont pas reconnus ne sont pas
indemnisés c'est la raison pour laquelle
pour le secteur du livre nous proposons
d'élargir le fonds pour les auteurs qui
a été mis en place par le gouvernement
mais qui ils nous l'ont dit d'ailleurs
représente si peu que ça mais ça n'a pas
de sens à d'autres questions
eh bien nous vous remercions